depuis six mois ils viennent se
recueillir dans leurs temples les
fidèles de l'église de jésus-christ des
saints des derniers jours appelé aussi
mormons sont de plus en plus nombreux à
venir ici au chesnay en moyenne près de
70 personnes par jour en provenance de
toute la france a les premières
impressions de nos fidèles qui sort du
dans ce bâtiment c'est bien évidemment
la la joie d'avoir un temple beaucoup
plus proche que ce qu'ils connaissaient
les contacts que nous avons eus avec les
voisins sont sont positifs extrêmement
positif il y à des personnes qui
viennent régulièrement dans le jardin
pour apprécier le lieu pour se
recueillir également un regard des la
statue du christ et penser au christ
lors des travaux lancés en 2013 certains
riverains s'inquiéter des recours devant
le tribunal administratif des pétitions
signées aujourd'hui plus aucune
inquiétude et un climat d'apaisement
plane autour du temple
j'ai déjà visité dès le début si vous
voulez les l'ouverture comme on est
voisins on a trouvé ça magnifique volée
c'était des très bien on a visité
l'intérieur et doux oui j'étais un très
beau temple
si on m'avait intéressé
on avait dérogé des gens qui nous avait
expliqué
les cérémonies les baptêmes tout ça
parce que vous avez su poser
collectivement
d'ailleurs nous le temple derrière non
pas du tout parce que vous savez ce que
c'est du tout une exposition
internationale de crèche sera organisé
du 13 au 23 décembre dans le centre des
visiteurs
un choeur interprétera des chants de
noël dans les jardins entre 18 et 20
heures